wir sind unterwegs nach kentucky im
südosten der usa
das leben hier folgt einem anderen
rhythmus als themen new york oder
washington
wir treffen eine frau die nicht möchte
dass wir kleines haus zeigen ihre
adresse nennen
im september hatte sie uns einen
datensatz mit mehr als 30.000 dokumenten
zukommen lassen
ein teil der daten ist mittlerweile
öffentlich zugänglich wurde sogar als
beweis vor us-gerichten zugelassen
es geht um illegale versuche der
republikaner ihre macht dauerhaft zu
sichern
das gros der daten ist noch überhaupt
nicht ausgewertet einige liegen uns
exklusiv vor eines würden sie schon
jetzt zeigen davon ist stefanie hofer
überzeugt wer nämlich für die
wahlerfolge der jumps und der
republikaner in der vergangenheit
verantwortlich sei ihr vater das ziel
meines vaters war es nach dem barack
obama gewonnen hatte ein system zu
schaffen in dem der republikanische
präsidentschaftskandidat immer gewinnen
würde
egal wie viele wähler nicht für ihn
gestimmt haben
es gibt nur wenige fotos von thomas
hoffäller hier mit tochter stephanie er
liebt die diskretion die mächtigen der
partei schätzen
schon seit den 70er jahren beschäftigt
er sich mit wahlkreis gestaltung für die
republikaner
in den meisten bundesstaaten liegt das
recht für die wahlkreis gestaltung bei
der jeweils regierenden parteien
parlament und wie die wahlkreise
gestaltet werden hängt jeweils vom
demokratischen grundverständnis ab
ein beispiel
in einem bundesstaat stimmen regelmäßig
60 prozent für die blaue partei und 40
für die rote der bundesstaat ist in fünf
wahlkreise aufgeteilt die jeweils einen
abgeordneten stellen in dieser wahlkreis
einteilung stellt die rote partei zwei
abgeordnete und die blaue 3 das
entspricht den mehrheitsverhältnissen
hätten die blauen die möglichkeit die
wahlkreise einzuteilen
dann könnte blau alle abgeordneten
stellen die roten gingen leer aus
was aber wenn rot die chance hätte die
einteilung vorzunehmen
das könnte dann zu der für eine
demokratie absurden situation führen
dass die minderheit die mehrheit der
abgeordneten stellt
[Musik]
so wie zum beispiel im roten
republikanisch regierten bundesstaat
wisconsin bei der lokalen
abgeordnetenhauswahl 2018 gewinnen die
demokraten zwar 54 prozent der stimmen
stellen aber nur 36 prozent der
abgeordneten die republikaner stellen 64
prozent der abgeordneten bei nur 45
prozent der erhaltenen stimmen
ähnlich sieht es in pennsylvania oder
north carolina aus nach us-recht aber
ist das alles völlig legal
als barack obama 2008 zum ersten
schwarzen präsidenten der usa gewählt
wird und klar wird dass sich die
bevölkerungsstruktur zu ungunsten der
republikaner entwickelt starten sie die
operation bet map einer der köpfe
dahinter thomas hoffäller stefanies
vater operation red mad begann mit der
idee dass man gewinnt wenn man das
interesse der nationalen partei geweckt
hat und einfach eine absurde menge geld
in eine wahl investiert wenn sie zum
beispiel von der 1000 dollar in eine
regionale wahl stecken hat ihr gegner
keine chance sein budget beträgt
vielleicht zu 5000 dollar mehr als 30
millionen dollar startkapital
investieren die republikaner in
operation rap map um die bundesstaaten
zurückzuerobern wie der rot zu färben
das ziel in möglichst vielen staaten an
die macht zu kommen um die
wahlgesetzgebung zu kontrollieren
thomas hoffäller spielt dabei eine
zentrale rolle in einem brief der
republikanischen parteiführung 2009
heißt es zitat dr hoffäller wird von
vielen als der führende experte für die
neue einteilung von wahlkreisen gesehen
das nationale komitee der partei ist
erfreut darüber seine leistungen für
diesen kritischen prozess gesichert zu
haben
als kooperation startet haben die
republikaner in zehn bundesstaaten die
absolute kontrolle über die neue
einteilung von wahlkreisen
drei jahre später sind es bereits 21
auch durch die millionen der operation
redman 2018 stirbt thomas hoffäller
seine tochter stéphanie sucht bei der
haushaltsauflösung nach einem
schmuckkästchen aus ihrer jugend was sie
dabei findet sind festplatten
sicherungskopien des computers ihres
vaters darauf zehntausende dokumente aus
ihnen geht hervor dass thomas hoffäller
mit hilfe riesiger datenmengen oft bis
auf den häuserblock genau entlang von
hautfarbe und eben ihre wahlkreise
analysiert und neu entworfen hat
stefanie erkennt dass der inhalt von
grösster politischer brisanz ist es ist
erlaubt diese wahlkreise zum eigenen
politischen vorteil zu gestalten aber
nicht zugunsten einer echten mein vater
aber hat es perfekt verstanden wie man
genau das erreicht deshalb wollte er die
unterlagen unter verschluss halten und
sicher gehen dass die demokraten nicht
herausfinden mit welchen daten schlüssel
er die bezirke manipuliert hat das
sollte verborgen bleiben
der fall die mit ihrem vater über jahre
zerstritten war
über gibt einige der festplatten einer
bürgerrechtsorganisation anwälte eines
republikanischen abgeordneten fordern
daraufhin die einstufung der dokumente
als geheim und dass alle kopien
vernichtet werden
ein gericht aber lehnt das ab
sie haben versucht zu verhindern dass
die akten als beweismittel bei der
anfechtung von wahlkreisen für den
us-kongress verwendet werden warum
hatten sie so viel angst davor weil sie
belegen dass die ethnie ein wichtiger
punkt war
wenn mein vater die bezirke eingeteilt
hat
[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs sind texas
auch hier hatte thomas hoffäller seine
finger bei der neueinteilung der
wahlkreise im spiel
[Musik]
texas bislang fest in der hand der
republikaner droht zugunsten der
demokraten zu kippen die demographie des
nach kalifornien bevölkerungsreichsten
bundesstaates ändert sich seit
jahrzehnten die latino und black
community wächst immer schneller
städte wie houston dallas oder die
hauptstadt austin sind längst hochburgen
der demokraten zu melden aber haben sie
texas nichts
in austin treffen wird stefanie swanson
von der organisation vernetzt texas die
wahlkreise sind stark zum vorteil der
republikanischen partei ausgerichtet sie
sind überhaupt nicht proportional sie
haben die liberale basis in fünf
distrikte aufgespalten und diese
distrikte erstrecken sich über riesige
ländliche gebiete in manchen fällen über
hunderte von kilometern die
demokratischen hochburgen werden in
kleine teile aufgespalten und dann mit
riesigen ländlichen konservativ
republikanischen landstrichen
zusammengelegt über 300 kilometer von
ost bis an die stadtgrenze von fort
worth erstreckt sich zum beispiel der
fünfundzwanzigste wahlbezirk in den so
zugeschnittenen wahlkreisen haben
demokraten dann keine chance mehr
selbst wenn sie im bundesstaat in der
mehrheit wären und das hat konsequenzen
auch jetzt für die präsidentschaftswahl
und diese abgeordneten sind es dann die
die wahl gesetze und regeln für ihren
bundesstaat festlegen
viele konservative neigen generell nicht
dazu das wahlrecht zu erweitern und den
zugang zu den wahlurnen zu erleichtern
besonders hier in texas sprechen sie mir
über die sicherheit von walen und davon
dass betrogen und wahlen bestohlen
werden
jetzt im wahljahr 20 20 trägt die
operation rap map ihre vollen früchte an
den schaltstellen entscheidender
bundesstaaten setzen treue gefolgsleute
des präsidenten mit voller kontrolle
über die organisation der wahl
der präsident steht mit dem rücken zur
wand donald trump liegt in allen
umfragen deutlich hinter seinem
herausforderer dabei ein wahlsieg
scheint immer unwahrscheinlicher eine
rekordzahl an bürgern lässt sich für die
wahlen registrieren und vor allem
demokraten beantragen wegen der pandemie
briefwahl der präsident bläst zum
frontalangriff
wir werden hunderte millionen
briefwahlunterlagen in ganz amerika
verschicken es ist alles manipuliert ihr
werdet das wahlergebnis wochen monate
nicht kennen vielleicht sogar niemals
erfahren das macht mir sorgen
beweise für millionenfachen wahlbetrug
legt er keine vor
aber er ernennt einen seiner großspende
zum chef des us postal service zuständig
für die auslieferung und zustellung der
wahlunterlagen
dessen erste amtshandlung ist die
stilllegung von sortiermaschinen und der
abbau von tausenden briefkästen im
ganzen land offiziell aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen weil viele
wähler verunsichert sind um ihre
wahlzettel rechtzeitig ankommen richten
die gemeinden sogenannte briefwahl
abgabe stationen ein
um das wählen zu vereinfachen aber dort
trump kann sich auf seine
republikanischen gefolgsleute in texas
verlassen dass hier hilft leuten die
nicht ins wahllokal gehen wollen und die
sich nicht auf die post verlassen wollen
und warum gibt es nur eine solche
station unglücklicherweise hat greg
abbott unser gouverneur in texas am
ersten oktober ganz plötzlich aus
heiterem himmel angewiesen dass alle
weiteren stationen in unserer und in den
anderen gemeinden geschlossen werden
müssen
das war eine beabsichtigte störung des
verfahrens es gab keine erklärung keine
warnung vorher nur macht alles durch elf
solcher stationen hatten sie allein in
austin geplant als der gouverneur am
nachmittag bevor es losgehen sollte die
gemeinden an weist auf eine station zu
reduzieren und das obwohl einige der
gemeinden in denen die meisten schwarzen
und latinos leben fast siebenmal so groß
sind wie das saarland oder mehr wähler
haben als hamburg einwohner
die anfahrt kann schon mal bis zu zwei
stunden dauern
das ist alles geplant und das ist es was
wir meinen wenn wir afroamerikaner
minderheiten und latinos leute die wir
über systematischen rassismus reden
hinter diesem rassismus steckt ein
system systematischer rassismus mehrfach
haben wir greg abbott den gouverneur von
texas und krampf vertrauten schriftlich
und telefonisch angefragt wollten von
ihm wissen warum er kurz vor den wahlen
die regeln ändert warum er es den wlan
schwer macht zu wählen
bis heute keine antwort aus dem umfeld
aber heißt es man wolle lediglich
wahlbetrug vorbeugen
wir haben uns mit louis roberto wer
verabredet ein angesehener erfolgreicher
anwalt
seit vielen jahren kämpft er gegen die
versuche der texanischen regierung die
wahlen mit allen mitteln zu manipulieren
im vergangenen dezember konnten er und
kollegen einen massiven versuch von vela
unterdrückung abwehren
der gouverneur innen und justizminister
hatten sich getroffen und dann
beschlossen dass sie den einfluss der
lateinamerikanischen wähler verringern
müssen also gingen sie hin benannten
hunderttausend wähler und behaupteten
einfach es seien alles illegale wähler
weil sie keine bürger der vereinigten
staaten sein
sie sagten es einfach so ohne jegliche
daten dafür zu haben
louis werde aber konnten nachweisen dass
alle bürger die von der wahl
ausgeschlossen werden sollten us-bürger
sind auch die begrenzung der briefwahl
abgabe stationen auf eine pro gemeinde
von heute auf morgen sei nichts anderes
als ein perfider versuch die stimmen der
schwachen der minderheiten zu
unterdrücken wenn sie der post nicht
trauen angst haben sich mit corvette
anzustecken
dann müssen sie 40 50 meilen fahren um
ihre stimme an einer briefwahl urne
abzugeben wenn sie es sich leisten
können würden sie das tun
für sie und welcher die meisten ihrer
zuschauer machen fünf dollar für benzin
nichts aus zehn dollar für benzin oder
was immer es auch kosten
doch wenn sie arm sind dann werden sie
nicht 23 dollar ausgeben
das ist der unterschied zwischen brot
milch für ihre kinder eine dosis
paracetamol
verstehen sie was ich meine dann werden
sie nicht wählen
ganz aber verstehen wir das nicht in
diese beschränkungen würden ja auch
republikanische wähler betreffen aber
auch darauf hat lewis werde aus langer
erfahrung eine klare antwort es ist eine
einfache machiavellistischen taktik okay
wir verlieren so und so viele
republikaner nun die sind entbehrlich
aber wir werden drei vier mal so viele
demokraten verlieren und das ist es was
sie wollen sie scheren sich einen dreck
um ihre eigenen wähler alles was sie
interessiert ist macht und politik
[Musik]
louis wäre und die organisation
lateinamerikanischer us bürger haben
gegen den gouverneur geklagt drei von
donald trump den republikanern ernannte
bundesrichter aber haben die klage
abgewiesen
[Musik]
von san antonio texas geht es für uns
1500 kilometer richtung osten nach
florida
hier könnte sich die
präsidentschaftswahl entscheiden florida
gilt als sogenannter swing state oft
liegen die kandidaten hier nur wenige
tausend stimmen auseinander
auch deshalb kommt auch ein tramp im
wahlkampf immer wieder nach florida
versucht die wahl hier für sich zu
entscheiden
und auch hier stellt er den wahlprozess
in frage die wollen unendlich lang
auszählen
ihr wisst schon die fans dem zettel
sie tun alles um ihren kandidaten zu
schützen sleepy joe die schlafmütze
derzeit wird florida komplett von den
republikanern kontrolliert und auch hier
zeigt sich was operation rap map für die
wahl am dritten november bedeuten könnte
wir haben uns verabredet mit referent dr
in seiner radiosendung diskutiert er mit
höherer und studiogästen glaubensfragen
aber auch warum diese wahl so wichtig
ist und er freut sich dass wir da sind
und berichten was in diesem war ja in
amerika die so los ist
holmes ist pastor der baptist church in
tallahassee die kirche gleich nach dem
ende der sklaverei gegründet ist ein
symbol für den kampf der schwarzen für
freiheit und gleichberechtigung martin
luther king hat hier gepredigt und wie
er ist referent holmes heute eine art
ikone der schwarzen bürgerrechtsbewegung
normalerweise ist die kirche brechend
voll aber wegen kurven sollen die
meisten gemeindemitglieder zu hause
bleiben
gottesdienst virtuell systematischer
strukturellen rassismus hat immer
versucht zu verhindern dass menschen ihr
recht zu wählen nicht wahrnehmen können
wenn du wählen kannst dann kannst du die
politik verändern
eine atmosphäre schaffen in der deine
leute die chance auf wirtschaftliche
entwicklungen gute bildung haben oder in
der du gerechtere umweltstandards
schafft das system aber versucht die
menschen am wählen zu hindern um sie so
mental in der sklaverei zu halten
referent spricht dabei unter anderem von
menschen wie elisa reddig die eine ein
frau auto reinigungsfirma betreibt
eigentlich wollte sie krankenschwester
werden hatte die ausbildung schon
begonnen
doch daraus wurde nichts als ihr
gewalttätiger ehemann sie verprügelt und
die polizei die beiden trennt beißt sie
einem polizisten im eifer des gefechts
in die hand und wird zu einem jahr
gefängnis verurteilt
das war vor 27 jahren und dieser bis
verfolgt sie bis heute
ein paar jahre nach meiner entlassung
habe ich herausgefunden dass ich nicht
mehr wählen darf ich habe dann ein
gnadengesuch eingereicht um ein
wahlrecht wieder herzustellen
aber dafür musst du erstmal fünf jahre
warten dann kannst du den antrag online
stellen und deine papiere zusammentragen
und dann kannst du nur noch hoffen und
beten dass jemand auf die zukunft und
die eine anhörung gibt und eine rechte
zurück zu bekommen
aber niemand hat sich bei mir gemeldet
lange zeit war ein gnadengesuch an den
gouverneur die einzige möglichkeit das
wahlrecht zurückzuerlangen
wer wegen einer straftat verurteilt
wurde hatte in florida das recht zu
wählen verwirkt auf lebenszeit
er lese hat sich in den vergangenen 25
jahren nichts mehr zuschulden kommen
lassen
zwei kinder großgezogen und hat sich mit
ihrem geschäft einen kleinen wohlstand
aufgebaut
an den wochenenden ist sie mit ihrem
motorrad club unterwegs und doch sei sie
nie wieder ein vollwertiges mitglied der
gesellschaft geworden
ich fühle mich wie eine bürgerin zweiter
klasse ich darf arbeiten und ich muss
steuern zahlen und ich dafür politische
repräsentation zahlen die ich nicht habe
denn ich darf niemanden ins amt wählen
so habe ich nicht die repräsentation die
ich brauche dann 2018 aber wendet sich
das blatt scheinbar auf initiative einer
bürgerrechtsorganisation stimmen 65
prozent der bürger floridas dafür dass
die verfassung des bundesstaates
geändert wird dass häftlinge die ihre
strafe abgesessen haben wieder wählen
dürfen
ein game changer wie man in amerika sagt
wenn es geht immerhin um 1,4 millionen
neue wahlberechtigte etwa die hälfte
schwarze und latinos aber die haben die
rechnung ohne die republikaner gemacht
die die gesetzgebung und die regierungen
florida kontrollieren
rund 60 prozent der bürger in florida
haben ja gesagt und dann kommen meine
republikanischen freunde im parlament
und bauen neue barrieren auf und sagen
okay aber ihr müsst erst alle eure
gebühren und bußgelder bezahlen
so wurde das in den 50er und 60er jahren
gemacht das ist eine wahl steuer
warum warum wird das gemacht um sie zu
entrechten ist ihnen das recht zu wählen
kaum ist die verfassung geändert
verabschieden die republikaner ein
gesetz das ehemaligen häftlingen zwar
erlaubt zu wählen
so wie es die bürger wollten aber nur
wenn sie alle gerichtsgebühren und
bußgelder bezahlt haben die sie zum
zeitpunkt der verurteilung schuldig
waren viele haben das geld nicht einfach
so in der tasche um all die gebühren und
bußgelder zu bezahlen
das ist eine weitere art und weise der
wälder unterdrückung
wir sind mitten in kuwait viele haben
ihre jobs verloren
und wenn ich entscheiden muss meine
strafen und gebühren zu zahlen oder
meine familie zu ernähren
dann erinnere ich meine familie an dem
punkt sind wir
doch selbst wenn sie bezahlen wollen
müssen sie erst einmal herausfinden wie
viel sie wem noch schulden nahezu
unmöglich sagt uns die anwältin der
orden die gegen das gesetz vor gericht
zog
wir haben ein team von top-experten an
geholt einige der klügsten köpfe in
unserem land und wir haben sie gebeten
nach den unterlagen von 153 personen zu
suchen was nur ein bruchteil der 1,4
millionen ist in 98 prozent der fälle
war das nicht möglich
konnten sie die unterlagen nicht das
problem viele unterlagen aus den
vergangenen jahrzehnten sind nicht auf
computern gespeichert sondern lagern
irgendwo in kisten in irgendwelchen
behörden der staat aber sei nicht
verpflichtet den ex-häftlingen
mitzuteilen wem sie noch etwas schulden
urteilten die bundesrichter auch sie von
donald trump den republikanern ernannt
und sie lehnten die klage ab die folge
selbst wenn du das geld hast die
anforderungen zu erfüllen
was viele nicht haben kannst du nicht
herausfinden was du noch zahlen muss wer
aber wählt ohne genau zu wissen welcher
behörde er noch wie viel schuldet macht
sich nach dem von den republikanern
verabschiedeten gesetz potenzielles
wahlbetrugs schuldig und kann dafür
wiederum bis zu fünf jahre ins gefängnis
gehen das schreckt viele ab sich
überhaupt erst für die wahl zu
registrieren
und für elisa ist klar warum sie alles
daransetzen menschen wie sie hier in
florida von den wahlurnen fern zu halten
ich möchte niemanden im amt haben der
mich nicht als menschen sieht und ich
glaube die 1,4 millionen menschen fühlen
das genauso vieles könnte sich in
florida ändern wenn diese 1,4 millionen
menschen zur wahlurne gehen würden
da sich die machtverhältnisse in den usa
zu ungunsten der republikaner dauerhaft
verändern
genau das wollte ihr vater immer
verhindern erzählt stefanie hofer
solange erlebt habe er daran gearbeitet
wir wollen nicht dass sich jeder mensch
einfach so für wahlen registrieren kann
denn die art von menschen die noch nicht
registriert ist wird wahrscheinlich für
die demokraten stimmen in meiner
naivität habe ich ihn gefragt aber
sollten sie nicht wählen wie sie wollen
seine antwort die wissen nicht was gut
für sie ist
[Musik]
es wird eine schicksalswahl am dritten
november
sie wird zeigen ob die strategie der
operation red map aufgeht und die
demokratischen spielregeln in den usa
weiter außer kraft gesetzt werden
[Musik]